if you're white right and I'm polish in
Nicaraguan right and but if you were
white or looked at as a white you know
Whitey honky wiggers whatever they call
them you know
um
I don't know what they call them in
what do you guys call them yeah a couple
[__] you know little chabs right at
AR
um if you are chavs or just regular
white people poor white people then yeah
I felt like a lot of times
um when people think of like poor they
think of just uh ethnicities first a lot
of times you know and so
and you always feel bad anyway because
white people you're just supposed to
have money right so automatically out of
the gate you're like how the [__] do we
not have
a little bit more money than this right
right if you've had a couple generations
and you've shown up in the you know in
the correct uniform yeah how would you
not have a bit more of a you know
Treasure Chest you know but but you know
that's what you get born into and so
that's that and uh and yeah it kind of
feels like you don't really get a voice
sometimes you know
um and then
yeah so I think that was part of my
thing it was like
I'm I ride the same bus as the poor
black kids the poor we only had black
and white in our town
but like you know when people think of
um
when people think of yeah helping like
sometimes they they would miss us you
know it would feel like sometimes and
now also
maybe that's just a feeling and maybe
that's not even the reality but it was
my perception sometimes you know I
wasn't angry at black people for it I
just was like well this is my truth you
know right and sometimes it feels like
uh
they don't know where to put that truth
in like a mainstream
space right it doesn't fit that
if you're not if you're poor and white
and not a racist person or you know
somebody who's mating with their
you know siblings or whatever then
you um
they don't it's almost like yeah work
yeah like you don't exist but you do and
there's a lot of you yeah and and that's
really interesting because you know
whenever like you see people in the UK
like comedians do like what they would
call a racist voice they would use your
accent yeah yeah you know what I mean
like and immediately you're just
stigmatizing a whole load of people
the vast majority of whom are nice and
decent and whatever else yeah
yeah that was always crazy yeah I mean
that was really rough during like a lot
of um when the Trump and Hillary I think
it was I think that was the campaign but
one of the campaigns it was like
everybody just started really the last
people that Hollywood was a or like I
don't know if it's just Hollywood the
last people that really anybody felt
safe to make fun of in like mainstream
media felt like
um poor white people
you know yeah like we did it all
if we did it all we'd have [__] done
it differently yeah I mean we'd have
something to show for it you know so I
think that yeah that [__] yeah but that
was the only one you could pick on so I
think it's Brave if somebody tries to
pick on somebody else you know I think
it's a little bit braver and I like that
that's one of the things that's always
kind of kept me wanting to stay in the
game is like how
how close to the middle of that
tightrope can I get you know right
um so you like getting close to the line
and feeling a bit of that heat there
yeah dude
yeah I mean I'm you know I don't like to
pretend that I'm like a fancy person or
that I've never done things wrong or
anything like that I've you know I'm not
I'm far from anything I'm just a regular
person you know just trying their best
or whatever I don't know but like I
never
you know I never what was the question
again
I was talking about getting close to the
line
oh yeah I wish that they would [__]
you know I wish that if everybody was
more cool then I think the line would be
it would be a lot more fun you know so
you feel restricted
let me think
do you feel like there's jokes that you
want to do that you're worried about
doing is that what you mean yeah man
yeah I do but also I think you gotta be
also like crafty yeah you know like if I
hear something that's just like racist
or just [__] like that [__] makes me
mad but if you have something that is
creative then that always should be able
to at least be
admired in some way you know yeah but
now yeah it's a little bit more cagey
what's it like in your country
really yeah yeah so comedians have been
arrested for jokes we've had
investigations by the police into into
comedians telling jokes someone told the
joke and the police turn up and go
explain that joke to us what if you
tickle someone
that's harassment yeah that's sexual
assault oh yeah but yeah but that's
where we are in in the UK man damn bro
y'all gotta get out dude get another
boat we'll send the boat back over tell
me about it but there's no other there's
nowhere new place to go now you know
yeah because I thought a lot of people
were going to come back to you guys in a
boat